I saw a little better care to brothers
and sisters indifference welcome terms
we actually do a Muslim like us what
we're in a reaction video a way for most
of the Congress supposed to do with me
it's running a bit late I'm gonna carry
them and when he comes we're gonna kind
of a circle punch Allah la ilaha illa
allah muhammad era sylvilla a hundred a
or b lie to me enough money rahim Maliki
or Medina sirat al-mustaqim Filipina
[Music]
on the surface so far so good good dog
Muslims judge each other too much we're
kind of hold each other to these
impossible standards and it's not fair
and it's not kind she's right she's
right to a certain point that we look
for perfection sometimes too much you
know he was actually contacted and I'm
sure it was this was very similar to us
or this to be on this program and I saw
that they sent Fischer gone and there's
an agenda behind it and I wasn't happy I
didn't go ahead with that
very true
that there is so true that I'm gonna
walk in and mr. Sharia law he's going to
see the hand heels and attack she writes
she truly touched on the way she looks
but my religion is a very very very
important part to me I pray every single
day now that there is something that we
can all learn from what we can learn
from that is that how many of us would
be watching this and would be thinking
no what she probably doesn't pray well
she's probably like whatever God God
knows what a lot of people think yeah
you know but the fact that she prays
every day masha'Allah I think truly that
teaches us not to judge anyone based on
outer appearance this is so so important
what's your name sir okay I mean we
started waiting Charlotte thank you not
much I thought he's on point with the
fact they can see the door with his gaze
and you know he's just you know trying
to avoid eye contact and he's given a
leaflet about free mixer which is but
I've been reminded benefits a believer
the profits olive oil or sometimes in
Abdul Haq also believes he should have
alway making eye contact with women you
know respect with that he might seem
abnormal you might seem out of place
understand thus our religion and we
should be proud of that the fact that
he's doing that and his bonus game
there's something that I don't got to
have a family and I think for me in
Islam it's a place for you in this now
why would they be a place for you this
time
[Music]
how the hell is that pathetic that
understand what does the world falling
apart got to do with free mixing in
ruling Dallas once Allah tells us not to
do and start to mix freely I don't have
separates himself from the group and
they go straight for the knife
when the Quran doesn't say Phoenix's
Haram how about don't even come close
don't come near to zina so meaning
anything that could lead to that stay
away from it
one of the biggest forms of loyalty zina
is free medicine he says no pre-mixing
[Music]
expression of truth then don't criticize
them and tell them he's disrespecting
you know what is respected one thing
just what makes you happy what makes a
lot of people yeah my mom my Nana and my
sister got together so - mouths I got
phone call you're getting married by the
way
okay thank you
[Music]
you just say boy or a girl cuz it'll
pray to traditional share go oh wait
nothing there's space for everyone to
find that so did she just say I write a
letter too good to me that's the stuff
it seems that she just stuck with her
always she just wants she just wants her
own Islam you know it's not it's not
what Islam was for most of what she
wants from Islam that's ridiculous like
seriously you and Esther got your way of
praying hood then they told you that
you know my school going play to get
home for me it gives you a really really
magical feeling and I can't explain it
it's a moment of peace you seem a lot
like you know the fact that she's you
know praying at the said before is much
like a really good you know you know
everybody has their own steps and
struggles in life and yes the fact that
she's not wearing a hijab and yes that
she dressed up in a certain way but then
again you know the fact that she's
trying and the fact that she is
issues in our community we are the best
oh ma that's reason yeah in the ways off
we've all been the message are enjoin
good and forbid evil you know that
certain aspects that we do that the
previous generations that the Christians
and Jews have changed and not one to
follow the Hellespont ever said that we
are superior in that context that we
tried to obey God Almighty as much as we
can so I don't understand what this
sister is trying to say we have this
shortcoming then is that now come the
yes we do what's that one do anything
else what does any where the greatest
one ma I don't understand I don't know I
feel like she's got this this bad
experience that she's gone through
totally and she just takes it out one
Islam you know
[Music]
how to wear the jewel of correcting and
it says it's based on clear-cut
evidences and not open to interpretation
about winning the independent one Oh
throw it in the bin
this is this is revelation from Allah
attending always how most mentally
dressed up his robot
however female should be dressed up and
she seemed throw in the bin but if this
is not ignorance I don't know what
ignorance is an absolute even is thrown
in the bin you know it's just like again
the antenna is just that she wants to
conform to society they just want their
own Islam but for this it just seems
that people just want their own Islam is
it so hard to say this is a ruling we
find a heart follow simple ones but
don't dismiss the ruling us so what okay
you accepted this time when he was a
baby
what does that change it doesn't change
anything Allah doesn't change you take
your shot before not black it's black
hideous thing you can imagine what Allah
sponsor ordered the Prophet the
Companions of wise listen the Sahaba and
she's calling it is it more important to
look like I'm asleep or feelings well I
think it's more important to look like a
Muslim and feel that comes late my
mother is the most highest person I come
across she okay after half didn't go and
say you have to wear a hijab to be a
good person he's just given a reminder
you know maybe knowing the best because
I was in doing it in a rude way it's
just a bit straight to the point but he
doesn't say anything he doesn't wanna
set you are this you are that if you
don't wear a hijab then I'm
said that and you can't a lot with buoys
and that if you went out with a boy that
would make you a prostitute well it's
not right for a female to well God knew
that it's okay for a guy to go out with
a deal it's not from Islam
this is this love you know it's as
simple as that all of the Muslims have
come to the house to show how they bring
Islam into their daily lives for one of
them this means overcoming one of the
biggest cultural taboos of all pouring
up particularly desire any relationship
wise I was relationship with you know
[Music]
what what is he talking about gay
phenomenal Glasgow and now lives in
London did you just say it was my best
this was get interested he's decided to
tell the groupies game while having
breakfast anytime change
did you see some changes culturally I've
been ostracized for being gay but now
I'm coming back into my faith is because
I've realized that actually being gay
and being of them are not mutually
exclusive things for my point of view
not a track for Islam because that is so
against anyone text
written in my fifth row
the mean is written in your fitter no
one has a right to tell you that you're
not almost named okay
now we can't say that somebody who is
gay has an inclination or practices it
is not a Muslim we can't say that that
is the Huaraz mentality of thinking
majors and thinker for this love we
can't say that
however if I come and do an example
phrase on myself if I come and say I
come in sin oh yeah yes zina is wrong I
need to fight that yeah I need to find
say I don't want to go home and sleep
around together when you practice it
it's a major sin this is the Old
Testament it's in Christianity it's in
Judaism innocent Islam it's a sin it's a
major sin the problem arises if I go out
and say me sleeping around is I don't
believe it to be Haram that takes me out
the photo is found because God Almighty
may has made it very clear
nice more permissive what an estimation
and it's Haram you sing it's not taken
for Islam you doing the Act doesn't even
though that act is wrong I'm not trying
to promote it it's wrong but for you to
say that it is permissible for me
because you have just made was Haram and
that was all you can make was another
wrong teacher for the Islam
probably so scary is for the absolute
end of her life but until we can make
understand proof of science if it was
why would you need science to determine
if something's Haram ha ha ha when the
hell has signs mean agnostic for us to
know what Allah wrong if even if its
genetic or biological doesn't change
anything
uncle Huck has decided to perform power
preaching Islam on the streets of York
and what's the rest of the house to help
oh oh oh oh oh it's bit of a big party
but there is so much humanity in Islam
which I'm sorry to say it's not that
reason I'm out I am of the opinion but
music is forbidden at least a type of
music what you would get in a in a pub
but I think it's important for me to go
so that people realize that I'm a human
and I'm not always a representative of
my religion you know what I don't
understand is that this is the state I'm
gonna go karaoke you know because you
know I don't get boys represent my
religion so I'm just gonna go and show
that I'm a human being
yeah now what do you mean by you're a
human being
like who said who define being a human
being is going out clubbing in a place
with less alcohol the Zener and all
these kind of stuff
that's their lifestyle yeah they think
that if we to do that their fact that
you define them being a human being is
going there and doing that it just shows
how Saddledome reality that we live in
as muslims it's really ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous what levels are
you gonna go to you know that's what the
prophecy sometimes said you're gonna
follow the people of the book pushes in
the Jews they're going to in littles
home you will follow them into that and
it's sad you know that the level of that
with controversy feel so inferior now we
have to show our says in the Quran that
people at the book will never ever ever
be pleased with you you go to a Papa go
karaoke go Christina they don't never
pleased with you I'm truly you leave the
religion that's our problem we sad to
see that coming out for my sister who
observes the hijab yes Japanese are not
perfect but you're cutting a uniform
that wasn't God as I was exposed to was
a very punishing lot well she's acting
like a lot just punishes because he's
stuff for a colossal spot I was bored
you know what would you expect you know
it's like hey let me do what I like
come is enough go I'll do whatever I do
everything that God doesn't want me to
do and then expect more punishment what
the hell are you talking about that
series that you won on that doesn't
wanna punish you Allison look around
what will not get out of punishing you
you wanna punish yourself
[Music]
my reason is insane dance fight not
seriously but I don't like calling names
to anyone but absolutely clowns behavior
absolute punishments like is that
they're just problem to just hey let's
just show this side of us you know this
is shorter than normal this but can you
be like seriously like how long it me be
like the guys are easy oh they hate you
they will attack your brothers and
sisters your father's out on the street
and you let me give me a hug how low can
you see you see what I mean to make oh
please you know tell me please I can
explain
aren't you you know I told us talking
about when this is your religion is now
though you don't think it's made nothing
to no one
this is Islam we are proud of our
religion of course she'll always I know
I don't like issues you know she just
it's not she until you I think she's
worse than I do